the minimalist want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now a wallpaper for your
smartphone now you'll always have a
reminder when you're getting ready to
purchase something new head on over to
the minimalists comm slash before to
download your free wallpaper today and
minimalists hello everybody welcome to
the minimalist podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua Fields
Milburn and my name is Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalists what
does your best life look like not your
Instagram life your real life that's
what we're going to discuss today it's
just me and Ryan in the studio I'm
excited man it's been a while
just the two of us just the two of us we
were gonna have Timothy J Ward on today
but he ended up in the hospital last
night yeah buddy we hope we hope you're
feeling better if you're listening to
this he has a great YouTube channel
we'll put a link to Timothy in the show
notes he talks about minimalism becoming
a minimalist what let him down that path
I really like his Twitter bio a says my
goal in life is to have very little and
want even less that's yeah that's great
man his videos are awesome in it's uh
they're inspiring dude yeah he's a great
example of I don't know just someone who
really got clear on what he wanted out
of life what his values were what his
priorities were and he went after it and
now I don't want to live Timothy's life
personally no but it is inspiration to
to have I don't know like I just it's
kind of like Collin right you know it's
like when I first saw him I'm like oh if
minimalism is owning only 50 things then
I don't want to do that but then I
actually saw what he was using
minimalism for right and then it all
made sense was like oh I could use this
for my life in a certain way but yeah
he's got a great recipe that you can
totally tweet some ingredients out well
he they're both using it Collin Timothy
and most minimalist I know are using it
to live their best life not the best
life as though there is a template but
they've sort of created their own
recipe for that so let's start by diving
into these questions the first one today
is from Gerry in New Jersey hi my name
is Gerry waters from South Jersey my
question is after you guys know let's do
the whole transition of becoming the
mothers you know you took things out
your life how how were those around you
accepting of it whether it's nothing of
it out of date how do they view they
think that you guys were weird did you
speak you guys were like going through
something serious but yeah I just wanted
to know how you guys dealt with the
people around you and how they came to
accept it Josh isn't a funny man when
when you make a major change in your
life I know this happens when you make a
major change so I'm gonna ask you if
this happens to you when I make a major
danger or anyone else that you know
you're friends with or respect or look
up to I know how much you look up to me
but when someone makes a change there's
this instant there's this instant thing
that happens where you feel like you
have to either accept or reject that
person's change and if you accept it or
if so speaking and for myself if I
accept it there's this mechanism in my
brain that's like oh well now I need to
make a change right I need to follow
that same path right if I reject it then
that makes me feel like oh I don't need
to make any changes I'm on the right
path
this person is crazy and then I will you
know
project that I don't do that so much
anymore because there is a third path
which most people don't take I feel okay
which is just accepting the differences
in being able to move on and support
that person even with their differences
I feel like Mike when it seems to be the
harder path to take we do right
absolutely
and because you say we have this
knee-jerk reaction I'll even take it a
step further for you Ryan is I think
sometimes the measurement of how much we
love someone is actually how much we're
willing to support them in that change
or in their new success or yeah or how
much we're willing to support their
differences that we have well I don't
think I'm just thinking about back in
like when we were in the corporate world
for example if I saw someone have some
sort of wild success like they were the
one president
and I didn't well it was hard for me to
celebrate that person yeah and now it's
it's easy like if you have a win Ryan or
if podcast Shawn has a win or Jordan no
more or social Jess anyone on our team
has a win then I feel like I'm winning
by proxy
yeah whereas before if someone achieves
something I didn't achieve here's a
really good example our good friend
Matty Avella who's directed our first
film we're working on our second film
with him right now it's called lesses
now they'll be on Netflix next year and
his YouTube channel has really taken off
oh yeah we don't focus on YouTube really
put our podcast up on YouTube but it has
not been a main focus for us our podcast
and our writing tend to be our main
focus and that has just taken off
millions of subscribers and I think my
old self would have been like what why
aren't I doing that yeah what are we
doing wrong what do i do err or I can't
believe he's so successful why in now
it's like wow like I feel like I'm
winning because Matt D Avella is winning
yeah and it takes a certain level of
maturity to get there but I think
ultimately what Jerry is asking is how
do you help encourage others to have
that level of support maturity and and
ultimately love ya know that's a great
question man uh cuz yes Jerry when I
first started down this path people
thought I was weird they thought I was
strange when Josh shut her down this
path I remember you know my boss asking
me is joshed is he depressed is he
thinking about killing himself because
he was giving away his things so yes
people absolutely judged and they
projected that judgement I have been
guilty of judging and projecting my
judgment so I think that knowing that it
helps me to get through it a little bit
more to kind of understand like people
aren't perfect and instead of me getting
defensive I can just kind of look at
someone and say you know what I
understand that this is a bit subversive
or maybe you know this creates a
visceral feeling and someone so they're
reacting based on this mo
that is happening but I don't have to I
don't have to react to that emotion but
here's ultimately why I didn't let those
people will affect me too much it some
of it hurt like don't get me wrong but
ultimately the people who were judging
me like I didn't want to live their life
right so like why would I why would I
get down on myself and and perpetuate
that that hurt because again like some
of it did hurt but I didn't perpetuate
it because I looked at the people doing
the judging and I'm like I don't emulate
these people anyway yeah or I don't want
to yeah and if I am emulating them I
want to move away from that emulation I
will add one there's a hidden secret
here Ryan and it is hiding in plain
sight and that's because we're so
wrapped up in our own identities in our
own head and what we think people think
about us most people when I became a
minimalist most people didn't notice and
the ones who did notice didn't really
care no one really cares that you're
simplifying your life and if they really
care about you then they care about the
changes you're making for the good if
they are judging you maybe they feel
like that they're being judged
themselves but I can tell you this if
you don't go around announcing the wild
changes that you're making yeah no one's
even gonna notice anyway yeah it's like
you can be a minimalist you can be a
vegan you can do CrossFit you could do
whatever it's okay as long as you're not
projecting judgment onto others uh-huh
as long as you know Jerry if you're
taking this path for yourself and you
are supporting other people and showing
other people respect and not judging
other people then that's probably going
to be mirrored back into your life now
if it's if there are some people who do
the judging again you've got to ask
yourself like do you really want to live
that person's life who's doing the
judging and if not I think that's what
he's worried about yeah he's he's
probably worried about well all these
people were going to judge me for the
changes that I make good if you actually
do have some people now it doesn't mean
to go on proselytize you have to go
say here's what I'm doing you need to do
this as well in fact I remember being
several months into my whole minimalist
journey I talked to Ryan about me I'm a
minimalist Verizon's like you're not a
minimalist like like because he had a
particular sort of idea in his mind
about what that word meant and and I
never went around and saying look at me
you need to become a minimalist too you
don't go around proselytize but good if
there are some people who are like hey
that's stupid or that's dumb I can't
believe you're doing this I can't
believe you changed your life oh well
you just told me that I no longer need
to spend my most precious resources on
you my time my energy my attention my
skills my love my caring I would rather
take those and provide those those
resources to people who who will benefit
from them yeah I'll tell you what Jerry
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life
there's a relationship chapter in there
it's a book about the five foundational
values in our life and right now you're
talking about the people in your life
you often hear me say you can't change
the people around you but you can change
the people around you and that's really
what that chapter is about if you draw a
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of minimalism live a meaningful
life it's our first book or we'll send
you the book book or the e-book if you
like those as well our next question is
from Justin in Denver hi this is Justin
in Washington Park Denver I've heard it
said that if you plan isn't working you
may have to change your blueprint my
question is is changing your blueprint
giving up on what you want out of life
so it's changing your blueprint giving
up on what you want out of life no it is
giving up on what you wanted out of life
in fact it's necessary to change your
blueprint in order to grow in order to
live what you might perceive as your
best life and let me give you a few
examples here my daughter six years old
if she continues to have the same
blueprint when she's 16 years old she's
going to live a discontented life yeah
and the same is true when she's 26 or 36
and so I think it necessarily has to
change because what we want out of life
necessarily changes and even for me in a
more narrow scope I embrace the
minimalism a decade ago when I was 28
years old my life is several times
different now from what it was then the
fundamentals are similar the same values
similar beliefs similar interests but
the circumstances have certainly changed
I live in a different place I have a
spouse and a kid I have different
friends and family we have a different
business from where we were we were in
the corporate world
we have several businesses I teach a
writing class online and so all of my
circumstances change and necessarily my
blueprint has to change otherwise I'm
going to be stifled yeah no I totally
agree man I think when it comes to your
once in your blueprint you do not
necessarily have to change your once not
necessarily the question is is whether
or not those once those desires if that
aligns with your values if that aligns
with living a meaningful life so what I
mean by that is like when I think about
money for example I just wanted money I
thought money was gonna solve all my
problems and didn't even know why right
right in that that was a problem because
money didn't accentuate my values that
didn't accentuate my beliefs it just
solved my money problems what what you
felt really big at the time and I think
that with the money thing you didn't
know why but you knew the you knew the
what right you didn't even know the how
money's gonna make me happy
and in the what was like I will buy this
what are you going to buy with the money
I'll buy a car I'll buy a house I will I
will do these things that's the what
how will you be happy I don't know it's
like that underpants thing what was that
from South Park whereas like the
underpants
yeah then step two question marks a
three profit right and it's good for you
it was like in me - it was like make
money step - mmm
happiness yeah no man it's it's it's
true it's like I
well first off I thought a million bucks
like having a million bucks in my bank
account like that is what was gonna make
me happy because then I'd be able to
focus on you know my real priorities and
what I have found out is that you can
live a really good life for way less
than 90 bucks but when you you know when
I got to the point where I was earning
you know well into six figures a year in
Ohio which is like I mean that's you
know you're basically a millionaire for
you
if you're picking over six figures in
Dayton Ohio I solved all my money
problems but then all that happened is
that I started to see all of the other
problems I had in my life a lot of those
problems couldn't be fixed with money my
health my relationships sometimes it
made worse with money yeah if you don't
have the right habits in place yeah
exactly man there's been watching the
show called the politician on Netflix
and it's uh it's about this kid who's
running for high school his class
president in high school yeah and it's
just it's a great show but there's this
line in there where this girl talks
about how the problem with being rich is
the the money makes the hard things easy
which then in turn make the easy things
seem hard so so when I got to a point my
life where I was like making the money I
wanted to make I was frustrated because
I'm like why do I have all these other
problems like I have solved all the hard
problems
so it just accentuated all the smaller
problems so Justin if you're chasing
things that don't align with your values
then yes you need to give those wants up
right and by the way you can give them
up temporarily too right so Ryan and I
we have this this rule we talk about
essentials non essentials and junk
another way to look at that is need want
like there are some things in our life
that we absolutely need and I think
they're pretty similar for most of us
there are other things that we don't
necessarily need but we want because
they add value to our lives yeah there
are other things however that are junk
and most of
myself included we justify the junk by
thinking pretending that it adds value
to our lives it's so true man when I
think about to my past life there there
were these once that I had you know
mainly chasing money uh-huh
I thought that if I was able to fulfill
that piece of it then it would bring me
enough contentment to ignore what was
going on so like right now I think about
you know I always talked about buying a
Tesla mm-hmm
they're slick they got the self you know
the autopilot they're eco-friendly I
mean there's just a long list of reasons
that I could totally buy a Tesla and
feel good about it but ultimately I
don't want to spend that you know 50
grand or whatever it is to to buy a
Tesla and I'm at a point my life now
where I can you know objectively look at
it and say I'm happy now yeah I'm
totally content now buying a Tesla is
not going to make me any happier I'm
just gonna stop wanting a Tesla and I
think that's one of the things we often
confuse I'll try to break this down real
quick I'm writing about this in our new
book I love people use things which will
be out in 2021 but we confuse pleasure
you would get some pleasure from buying
the Tesla especially immediately integer
and throughout I think you would it
would increase marginally increase your
pleasure
right and we confuse pleasure for
happiness then we confuse happiness for
contentment and then we confuse
contentment for joy and and these are
just different layers of the the sort of
satisfaction continuum here right and
we'll try to actually on the maximum
episode I'll try to go a little bit
deeper on on the difference between
those things I have one final analogy
here for Justin and because it's not
that you want to get rid of your desires
necessarily we're gonna have P Rollins
back on the podcast to talk about desire
and and this this concept of object a
and the Tesla for you is the object a
but we
our problems to get better and sometimes
what money does is it does help us in in
a wet weird way and it's uncomfortable
it illuminates some of those other
problems that you had where you thought
you were going to cover up the problems
with money paper paper mache over them
with hundred-dollar bills yeah like
being rich is gonna make me feel so good
that I'm gonna feel less bad about the
these other areas in my life no but if
you fix one one area of problems if it's
a money problem for example because now
you're on a budget you've paid off debt
you've worked really hard
you've earned more income whatever it
might be and now all of a sudden you
start to fix those money problems what
comes to the forefront whatever other
problems you have relationship problems
clutter problems problems with the truth
in your life problems with living a
discontented life that doesn't align
with the person you want to become maybe
you have other problems love life
problems or maybe have creative problems
problems with distractions these are all
problems that start to come to the
forefront that are by definition
preventing you from living your best
life however these are better problems
to have and what that really means and
to get to the core of Justin's questions
here are you giving up on your dreams
well well no you're changing your plan
because you're once have to necessarily
change over time it's just like playing
a video game if you play Super Mario
Brothers but you're always just playing
the first level over and over and over
it doesn't get any more difficult
because you've mastered that problem the
problems of that and you can get really
really good at it going through that
level faster and faster or faster but it
becomes boring it becomes monotonous it
becomes not worth even playing the game
and so what I would say is if your
blueprint doesn't change over time those
same things are gonna happen to you you
want additional challenge you don't want
a problem-free life you don't want a
life that is no anxiety no stress you
want the appropriate amount that allows
you to grow that area of disk
for the discomfort zone is a place from
which we grow the most
Justin I'd love to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing the ryan and i have ever
created and it's really about the
five-year journey of letting go for us
it's a story of giving up our old dreams
changing our as our once changed we also
changed our dreams along the way my
dream once upon a time was to be a
c-level executive I want to be the CEO
of this corporation that's not a dream
to me anymore that's a nightmare
and so sometimes our dreams turn into
nightmares on a long enough timeline and
so everything that remains is the story
of Ryan and I leave them behind those
old dreams those that template the
society provided for us moving forward
creating our own dreams and living more
meaningfully along the way we're sending
the audio book or the book book or the
eBook version if you'd like Justin Ryan
what time is it you know time it is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
indeed we do we are at the minimalists
on Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
you can you can find us over there you
can ask us your questions now what we do
during the lightning round is we try to
answer your questions with just a short
share but less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pit the answers
on social media if you like and now you
can find all of our mental minimal
Maxim's in one place over at minimal
Maxim's calm all right Stephen wants to
know how do you deal with the stress of
a society that's telling you what your
best life should be mmm well here's
something pity for you Stephen if you
follow someone else's recipe you will
bake the same cake but you might not
enjoy the taste so true you know here's
the thing someone else tells you here's
my recipe I like that I like looking at
people's recipes we were talking about
this very at the very opening I don't
want to follow Timothy J Ward's recipe I
don't want to follow Colin Wright's
recipe or Joshua Becker's recipe or or
godly Oh Bob Altos recipe I don't want
six kids I don't but I can look at their
overall recipe and say oh wow I'll
the taste of that ingredients just like
when you look at a bunch of different
recipes you might see a really great
recipe but you're like I hate onions and
garlic I don't I'm not gonna put onions
and garlic I like everything else about
that stew that you're making my not
gonna have onions and garlic it's
different from a template a template is
ready-made I have to follow it piece by
piece instruction by instruction it's
IKEA provides templates for their
furniture yeah and if you don't follow
that template I'm just gonna I'm gonna
do half of this you're probably not
gonna have something that is functional
with a recipe however you're able to
adjust it for taste and so Stephen how
do you deal with the stress of a society
that's telling you what your best life
should be don't worry about their best
life worried about your best life amen
I got a couple put the answers here for
you Stephen you'll never live your best
life living for others expectations so
the only expectations you need to worry
about are your own and that doesn't mean
to be selfish it doesn't mean to ignore
the people around you but what that
means is that you do have to put that
oxygen mask on yourself first before you
can actually truly give a hundred
percent if you're just living for other
people's expectations well then you're
you're always going to feel like you're
just barely getting above water you're
gonna feel like you're drowning in other
people's expectations the second pit the
answer I have is the best life is a
meaningful life so Stephen what is your
recipe for a meaningful life like that's
what you got to look at man there's one
thing I do want a caveat I want to throw
in here about the best life in Western
culture there is this like very there's
a societal pressure to love laugh live
dance like no one is watching
yeah I mean it is it's very cliche to
like you know live your best life but
here's the thing
you're never gonna live a 100% best life
it's it's like trying to find a
relationship that is 100% perfect does
it exist
sure I'm sure there are you know people
out there who have the
relationship in the best life 100% but
it's not the expectation to live a best
life which is a perfect life it's not
really a fair expectation to put on
yourself right I think I think I would
just delineate the two I I think a best
life is the best version of your life
and that's never going to be perfect
right and so maybe there's a few other
minimal Maxim's here there's something
like a simple life is the best life but
also the best life is not a perfect life
hmm
yeah that's good and and because what
we're really talking about our standards
versus expectations here right yeah you
if you expect everything to to be
perfect I got to a car accident last
week someone rear-ended me and and I'm I
remember walking away from that just
hugging backs cuz she was in the
passenger seat I was seated at a red
light back in Dayton Ohio and working on
this this film project les is now that
we're working on and I'm just sitting
there in LA and at the red light in a
rental car very soft music playing it's
William Fitzsimmons you know how soft
and sleepy his music is it's my last
night in Ohio and I'm just sitting there
and vivan out and all of a sudden I know
we're late mice my head snaps back total
whiplash right yeah and but I walked
away from it just with extreme gratitude
even though I was in pain my back really
hurt my neck hurt a huge inconvenience
and I'm gonna have to deal with all but
sam harris has this really great thought
experiment that i absolutely love we
have all these problems right now right
we're you're always gonna have problems
right but they're always gonna be
problems that are much worse than that
right and so let's say what's the worst
thing that could have happened and I
maybe I could have been paralyzed yeah
in in that car accident yeah I could
Beks could have died yeah how much money
would I pay to reverse that right I mean
the parallelization
right right and all of it how much would
I pay anything that I could pay for the
rest of my life to not be paralyzed all
of a sudden that provides me with a much
different perspective and realizing that
many of my problems aren't real problems
they're challenges that are actually
made that make my life interesting that
add variety to my life in a way that
then if I were just seated at a
mountaintop for the rest of my life yeah
meditating I wouldn't have that same
level of variety or fulfillment I don't
think this makes me think of another
thing from the politician it really is
like it's kind of an inspiring show but
uh there's this part where this mother
is explaining to her son like honey life
and I'll keep this clean because so far
we even cuss on the on the show and I
always like drop something and then it
ruins the whole show for being a clean
episode Ella likes hearing herself at
the beginning of the episode yeah so
it's uh she says honey life is a poop
tornado and it's got little bits of gold
in it what you have to do is figure out
how to grab those bits of gold as you
know as much as you can and the reason
why she's explaining this because her
son is explaining how life is it's like
a train you got your track and you know
now I've been derailed and she's like no
no like life is a torrent as a poop
tornado but a little bits of gold in it
you have to grab the gold but it got me
thinking that the best life man it's
learning how to be covered in poop and
be content with that oh that's good so
so maybe there's even a step farther
right hmm sometimes poop saves people's
lives fecal microbiota traces and so in
one scenario like I don't want to eat a
poop sandwich right I think they taste
like crap but if I need to maybe if I'd
seed if for example which I've actually
had in the past that people are using
fecal microbiota transplants now yeah
- literally cure c-diff which kills what
twenty-nine thousand people a year in
the United States I mean it's a pretty
big deal and so sometimes the thing that
we're grossed out by or that we think is
awful is also
thing that saves our lives yes I like
that ma'am all right we've got a bunch
more to get to before our added value
segment and our listener tips today
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week is there ever a
point where your best life and your
Instagram life are in alignment how do
you determine what your what your best
life is how do I ensure I choose a
partner that fits into my best life man
one of the most important decisions that
you're ever gonna make in your life
we'll talk about that how can I find a
larger sense of purpose in my life is
happiness the best goal in life if not
what is who has made you laugh the most
in your life and let's say we got about
7 billion more questions here about
minimalism today and if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I record an
entirely different much longer maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about topics we don't
usually discuss in public Plus patreon
is best way for us to fund this podcast
and keep it a hundred percent
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff including an additional private
podcast episode every week over the
minimalists com slash support I know
it's just a couple bucks but you get so
much for those couple bucks and we're
capping our patreon community at 6,000
people because we want to keep it
intimate we are approaching that right
now and so if you want to get in now is
a good time to do that no pressure you
don't have to do it immediately but if
you want to get in there we're gonna cap
it at 6,000 patrons right well you got
for us this week here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out hi this is Leslie from
New York and I just listened to your
most recent podcast about careers and
I've actually been really listening to
some of the older podcast may have
listened to one of the original career
ones as well and something I just wanted
to say for some of the listeners who are
struggling with their jobs not lighting
up to their you know their values is
that I'm a CPA and I
to work in corporate finance and do a
lot of financial statement analysis and
auditing for big corporations and I was
kind of getting you know disenfranchised
and just not really loving what I was
doing and what was the point and what I
do now is they still work as a CPA and I
still do work as an auditor and now I
work for companies I'm sorry I should
say I work for a firm that does a lot of
work with not-for-profits and so about
50% of my clients are not-for-profit
organizations and it's a good way to
align my values with what I do for a
living I'm able to provide these
not-for-profit associations with
solutions to some of their financial
issues help them invest their money
better and also help ensure the donors
that their money is being used in the
way that they would hope it would be so
just a way you know just something for
people to think about that you don't
necessarily have to completely jump ship
on your career to find a way to make it
align better with their values
hey there i'm krista from chicago and
this tip is for gina from episode 202
who is having trouble with consumerism
after downsizing her wardrobe i also
faced this challenge but i put a rule in
place that has helped me make more
deliberate and long-lasting purchases
when shopping i make a list of the
qualities the item must have from the
purchaser for example when i downsized I
realized I didn't have a good
cold-weather dress but instead of just
going out and buying one I made a list
of her qualities the dress needed to
have sweet debris named versatile and
practical it needed to be one cocktail
ring and relatively minimal and design
that way I can wear it to many occasions
on her many years without it looking out
of place or out of style when I went
shopping for the dress I stuck to those
three qualities because if it didn't
satisfy all three of those means I knew
I would just end up looking for another
one later and I finally found the right
one I bought it and I want it to last
six years about ever feeling the urge to
shop for another this rule really helps
me identify why I need an item they can
easily be applied not only to clothing
but to any potential alright y'all real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that is going on in the life
of the minimalists it's the holidays
Ryan Thanksgiving is this week and that
means well what does it mean holiday
giftgiving so make sure you get all the
appropriate gifts yeah we actually got
to talk a little bit on on patreon this
week about about some holiday
gift-giving and don't worry we're gonna
do we'll do some gift giving stuff on
the main podcast give so great as long
as there as long as it's not an
obligatory gift as and as long as it's
meaningful I mean yeah I mean I hate
because we are against like just you
know getting tie clips for each other
right but we're announcing today the
minimalist cuff links now if you are
looking to gift a consumable though we
we own a coffee shop down in st.
Petersburg Florida it used to be you
could only buy the coffee that we roast
between the four walls
it's called bandit coffee by the way you
can follow our coffee shop on on
Instagram we'll put a link to the
Instagram to bandit in the show notes
we're offering food down there now but
you can also order our coffee it's just
at the minimalists dot coffee is the
website
each month do the minimalist choice it's
what we're drinking currently what we
order personally so if you're looking at
gifting really good high-end coffee that
Ryan and I really enjoy well the
minimalist stock coffee is your place
but as Ryan said I wouldn't just give
gifts out of obligation you can do it
any time you don't have to wait until
December 25th say I got you something I
think is gonna add value to your life if
you buy someone coffee who doesn't drink
coffee it's a very your dad for yes you
already have a question commoner
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm just enter your email
address there at the top you'll also
receive our simple Sunday emails and for
our added value this week Ryan I was
driving around Ohio all last week backs
and I we could not stop listening to new
post Malone Elvis Goodman it is so good
it's my favorite album with his now I've
recommended his stuff before I think
it's total juvenilia I mean it's but
this album is he is a musical chameleon
yeah some of the songs on there are rap
songs some were 80s pop songs and
somehow they all sort of flowed together
seamlessly on one track he has Ozzy
Osbourne and Travis Scott on the same
song he's a good he's a good artist man
so I wanna closes out today with one of
my favorite songs from that album it's
called circles and the album itself is
called Hollywood's bleeding and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus